he just like yo-yo like a basic yeah yo
yo you go with this but this is not a
basic y no okay
that that is awesome ah nicely done
this is Ben Conte he's got a brand new
channel on YouTube which is about
yo-yoing like a crazy person but I'm
just going to figure out how this is
possible how is it possible with a
string that's not connected to the yo-yo
to get it to do all of these insane
things
how do you learn to do that that's crazy
uh it's a lot of like well me Saturday
nights
so watch this motion here there talk
about yeah you got it this is not gonna
have you gotta do what Oh check out Oh
what there you go Oh sky so how does
this work when the yo-yo is released it
on spools as it falls gaining kinetic
energy and rotational energy from the
gravitational potential energy it had to
start with yo-yos can spin really fast
around six thousand revolutions per
minute that's about as fast as most car
engines can turn over and this is
important because it gives the yo-yo
gyroscopic stability which means its
axis of rotation is maintained even if
there's a breeze or some little
disturbances now since the yo-yo has a
lot of angular momentum it continues
spinning in the same direction but when
Ben tugs the string he pulls it from one
side of the yo-yo over to the other so
now as the yo-yo continues spinning it
binds the string to the spool and starts
to roll up the string if you look
closely at this shot you can actually
see the exact moment when the string
binds to the spool preventing the yo-yo
from some raveling further and falling
off the string
that's all there is to it yeah no
science behind it at all to release the
yo-yo Ben throws it out and upwards
without pulling back so it completely
unspools and it continues spinning at
the same high rate of rotation but how
does he catch it with just a string so
the way yo-yos actually do roll up is
there's friction pads inside the yo-yo
these ones are made out of silicone you
see this like little gap on the inside
when that string goes inside that
creates friction and while it's spinning
it rolls the yo-yo up so if Ben can
lodge the string in the gap of the yo-yo
it catches on the friction pads and the
yo-yo starts to roll up the string again
even without the friction pads when the
string wraps around the axle it creates
a significant amount of friction in the
same way that ropes wrapped around
bollards hold big ships to their docks
the amount of tension a coiled rope or
string can hold is given by the belt
friction equation this equation shows
that the force the string can exert on
the yo-yo increases exponentially with
the angle the string makes around the
axle so even a few turns around the
yo-yo allow Ben to pull it back into his
hand what is your favorite yo-yo moment
my freestyle in 2011 the crowd stood up
and I felt good
brought tears in my eyes but I went back
to my hotel room to cry crippled happy
Hey this episode of veritasium was
supported in part by audible.com a
leading provider of audiobooks with
hundreds of thousands of titles in all
areas of literature including fiction
nonfiction and periodicals because
audible supports veritasium they give a
special offer to anyone who watches this
show if you go to audible.com slash
veritasium you can download and listen
to any book for a one-month free trial
and the book I'm listening to at the
moment is a classic of science fiction
it's Kurt Vonnegut's slaughterhouse-five
an awesome book about becoming unstuck
from time it involves aliens and world
war two and kind of this weird
time-travel but it's just a phenomenal
piece of writing so if you haven't read
it or listen to it and you can check it
out for a one-month free trial just go
to audible.com/veritasium I really want
to thank audible for supporting me and I
also want to thank Darren Dyke who
filmed the slow-motion shots in this
video he is phenomenal that's why this
video is so cool and also of course Ben
Conde because he spent years of his life
perfecting the skills that you saw
demonstrated here if you want to see
more of him you can go check out his
channel link is in the description so
again I want to thank all of these
people and I want to thank you for
watching